good morning everyone uh we are joined
today by dr teresa tam and dr howard new
we'll begin with an opening statement
followed by questions from our zoom
participants doctors
hello everyone bonjour to tattoos
last week's modeling update showed that
while our resurgence in cases could
still occur with the easing of public
health measures
the predicted trajectory for hospital
admissions is expected to be lower
for covet 19.
in the week since the modeling update
epidemiological indicators of covert 19
disease activity have continued to
improve across most jurisdictions
nationally weekly case counts are down
by 26 percent and the number of people
covered 19 in hospitals and icu's have
declined by over 20 percent compared to
last week
nevertheless as the sars kovi-2 virus is
still circulating widely
some jurisdictions are reporting weekly
increases in case counts and others
could see additional bumps in the weeks
ahead
as such canada continues to closely
monitor a range of indicators including
using wastewater surveillance for early
detection and monitoring the amount of
virus in community samples
at the same time there is continued high
volume of pcr testing being performed
and ongoing genetic sequencing of
circulating virus variants
while the ba1 sublineage of the omicron
variant is still dominant in most
provinces and territories we are picking
up an increasing presence of the ba2
sublineage which currently accounts for
about 10 percent of our domestic samples
based on preliminary case surveillance
data from denmark where ba-2 is now
dominant
this sublineage does not appear to be
associated with more severe illness
similarly data from england where ba2 is
steadily increasing shows no indications
of a difference in immune escape or
vaccine effectiveness compared to
omicron
that week omicron ba1
however both countries report that the
ba2 sublineage appears to be even more
transmissible than the ba1 sublineage
as with other variants of concern the
risk of infection and severe outcomes
are expected to be highest among the
unvaccinated
knowing that the vaccines are still
expected to provide substantial
protection against serious illness
really underscores the message that
people need to get their coven 19
vaccines up to date in particular
getting a booster dose if you're
eligible and especially for those age 50
years of age or older is very important
the evidence supporting the value of
booster doses continues to get stronger
recent studies indicate that an mrna
cover 19 vaccine booster dose enhances
the overall immune response which can
provide longer lasting protection and
possibly better effectiveness against
variants
so if you or a loved one are eligible
[ __ ] a covenant team boosted those i
would urge you to get that very
important additional shot of protection
now it's not too late in fact the time
to do this is right now
as we've said our best advantage going
forward is to maintain a state of
readiness
canada's public health authorities will
continue to adapt and share guidance and
recommendations to help guide us as and
when the situation changes
at the individual level in addition to
keeping covert 19 vaccinations up to
date readiness can be best achieved by
continuing to follow public health
advice which is tailored to local
epidemiology and circumstances to help
guide your individual and family risk
assessment and decisions on the use of
personal protective practices such as
masking thank you merci migrate
is
thank you we'll move to questions please
raise your hand on the zoom platform if
you have a question we'll begin with
dylan robertson winnipeg free press
uh hi there thanks for taking our
questions today uh dr tam i wanted to
ask about canada post's mask policy
the agency has been sending home staff
for wearing respirators instead of level
2 masks canada post says that
respirators can only be worn with a fit
test and that it's unfeasible to do a
fit test for a large number of staff the
canadian center for occupational health
and safety suggests that a fit test is
only needed when the device is meant to
prevent inhaling aerosols
the agency says that if canada post
objective is only about preventing
exhaling particles then a fit test isn't
needed
i realize that you don't run the postal
service but i'm wondering if you have
any sort of advice for these sorts of
accommodations
yes i'm not familiar with that
particular situation
but i think for the general public for
instance we are recommending getting the
highest quality
mask that you can
get your hands on essentially and that
includes respirators
and the key is to make sure that
the mass fits well against
your face covers your nose
your mouth etc so i think
that should be taken into account by
employers we certainly do recommend this
range of mass for the general public
and
i'm not
sort of familiar with the precise
policies
but i certainly think a respirator of
depends i i don't know the circumstances
under which kind of the post workers
work um
but
i think that for general public in the
the settings that a general public can
encounter
then you don't need an actual fit
testing this is not for a medical
situation like in a hospital
or in a long-term care facility even
where you you're taking care of uh sick
patients
so for those these kind of general
circumstances we have recommended as you
know uh this range of um face coverings
and mass and respirators
as um individuals
um see fit but we we do recommend the
highest quality mass that you can get
thank you and as a follow-up i'd like to
also get your advice for the public uh
when when people are living in provinces
where they're dropping masks and vaccine
mandates uh we know that federal
agencies and some private businesses are
keeping these in place i think you
mentioned at the end of your remarks in
english that you know masking might be
with us for quite a while
um
i don't know if you want to comment on
if it's prudent to draw those sorts of
measures but if you have nice with the
public in in areas where that is
actually being taken off the table quite
soon
yes i think um
masks continue to be i think a really
good
layer of personal protection and
i think that even if it's not required
in the jurisdiction that you're in or
the community that you're in
you can choose to wear a mask as a
personal protective
measure it's a habit that we've
developed over the last couple of years
and i think it's good for the prevention
of um
not just covert 19 maybe but maybe other
respiratory viruses as well
so i think that's really important
especially if you have a higher risk of
developing serious outcomes from
covert 19. so i think in the days and
months ahead we need to do a better job
in equipping individuals with the tools
that they need
to make those personal uh
base decisions
but i still think that mass remains one
of the foundational layers of protection
and it may be the last thing that you
want to remove in your personal
um
you know
armamentarium of of tools
and
the the same thing applies whether
you're going to different communities in
canada but also internationally where i
think travelers should also be equipped
with masks so that they can actually
wear them
depending on
the situation that they're in and the
community virus activity as well i think
that in in the months ahead in adjusting
to a new way of
managing and responding to cover 19
you might sort of think of
checking your local covet virus
activities but like going out checking
the weather
you would want to check on the weather
to put on a coat so check on the weather
and bring your mask with you if there's
virus activity and you're going into an
indoor setting with people who are
outside of your household for instance
and that kind of messaging and habit
we've developed over time and that needs
to be reinforced
and i think
all the public health departments are
trying to
do some of that
at the moment
and i think
the members of the public could also
give feedback as to what kind of
information that they still need and
that will be helpful to all of us
it's dr new the other point maybe i
would add to what dr thomas said is that
i think there's a distinction to be made
between sort of you know policy in terms
of obligatory use of face masks versus
as a dr tam said a sort of a personal
empowered choice you know to to make in
terms of uh wearing a mask because
you're concerned for your own personal
protection it's another layer of
protection that's uh without doubt i've
been shown by by uh the science and so
on and and so the other point is as we
move forward we also want to make sure
that we don't stigmatize and
and make it uh uh difficult for
individuals who choose to maybe want to
wear a mask for lots of reasons maybe
your immuno compromise or for for other
reasons you would like to protect
yourself or maybe uh avoid maybe a
possibly transmitting it to others in
your family you might be also at higher
risk so i think it's all about uh
choice as well but also making sure that
that people make those personal choices
that that we also support them in making
the choice to wear a mask thank you
thank you next question goes to olivier
fedor
bonjour um
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
uh
foreign
uh
and make decisions based on that thank
you thank you we'll move to jamie
morocco with global news
hi everyone um i'm just going to fall
back to the math question and ask you to
clarify a little bit more i know that
you guys are not in the business of
making policy but you are in the
business of making recommendations for
health so can you be very very clear
so you're saying you want or you think
people should still still wear them so
are you
recommending that
mandates not be lifted right now would
that be can you just be very clear about
what it is that is the health
recommendation when it comes to masks
health recommendations masks provide a
good layer of protection
it's a fundamental layer of protection
for people
and you could ask people to wear a mask
in different ways
so i think many of the provincial
territorial
medical officers house are saying that
what they switching to
is from requirements to recommendations
that's which isn't always easy to do
um certainly
most of this is not within the federal
jurisdiction but i think our
recommendation is that
uh we're asked to reduce your risk for
covert 19 and get the highest quality
well-fitted mask and wear them properly
as part of your protection weather
your jurisdiction requires it or not or
whether a certain setting requires it or
not it is something that you can do to
protect yourself
and and others so
right now uh the key
to recognize for most
people in this country is that the the
virus is still still very much
alive it's active in your communities
so even if there's no requirements
um
depending on the virus activity level
people should choose to wear masks it
should be probably one of the most
foundational layers that you can use
um but i think though the switch from
requirement to recommendations is simply
a very difficult one and it is difficult
for businesses and other organizations
to transition
as well because it's actually quite
simpler almost if
public health or other policies are in
place
that just makes the messaging and the
requirements simpler but
we've got to begin to move
beyond requirements and adapt our
personal habits as well to
to prevent
virus infections
and just to follow up um if you could
answer in english
on
whether you feel like masking in schools
could be lifted at the same time as
the general public is that a good
decision at this point based on where we
are with hospitalizations and case
counts and all that sort of thing
yeah i still think that masks are a good
layer protection and it's something that
people got used to using
um and that kids or parents should feel
that perfectly comfortable and be
supported in their kids wearing mass if
they choose to
right now i think what quebec is saying
is that they've looked at the
vaccination rates they've looked at some
of the antibody studies in their
populations for school age i believe
it's more the 12 plus
but they have data that they're using to
base their policy decisions on
we know that the omicron wave has
caused quite a lot of infections
and if you had two doses of vaccine and
you got infected that's probably quite a
good a reasonable level of protection
against omicron
we still have to watch out for the next
variant
and i think people even if they remove
the policy
um
should be alerted to the fact that
if another variant occurs
that is
vaccine or immune escape be prepared to
have your mask ready for that moment in
time when we may have to
re-escalate some of these measures and
what we no one wants to do is to see
schools being shut down again i think
that is
a collective
goal for public health
um systems across the country
and if
mass has to be reinstituted at some
point in time then that is a i think
a
a
a
layer of protection that people can use
i i guess the message is that even if
the policy is removed
based on the data on the ground
um i think uh the members of the public
should remember that they should be
ready to um
re-engage and
get those layers of protection um on we
don't know when
i think monitoring and surveillance is
very important we're certainly planning
towards the fall because that's where
respiratory viruses can often
re-escalate but any time between now and
the fall we still could be surprised by
this virus
and be prepared
to
put some of these policies back that are
not not as restrictive if you like
i think people should do everything they
can to keep schools open then by the way
that also includes i think we hope some
improvements in ventilation systems and
other measures
at schools as well
thank you next question laura osmond
hi doctors thanks so much for taking our
questions today dr tam i wanted to just
pick up um exactly where you left off
there i remember
last fall before omicron we were talking
about
you know the possibility in the spring
we could be talking about the pandemic
being over that was before omicron hit
us all now we're seeing
vaccine mandates being called down mass
mandates being called down the
implication being that they're not going
to come back so i'm wondering if you can
you know help people adjust their
expectations could
these big government public health
managers
see a return in the fall or
are we moving into a future without
those
well i think um what i was saying is
that you know we're gonna get a bumpy
ride over the winter months and we hope
to be in better place in the spring
a pandemic is a global phenomenon so um
even if the virus activity uh
comes down in canada that's not to say
that the pandemic has disappeared
more more we learn about this virus the
more we understand that it's not gonna
disappear it's it's not just in humans
it's in certain animal species as well
so that makes it really difficult to um
really get you just can't get rid of it
so what will happen to
the virus and its interactions with
humans
there's different scenarios but
nonetheless we must not forget that this
virus will still be with us
and hence the need to adapt
how we
manage
the
resurgences if you like going forwards
i think um
what we're hoping
collectively across the country
is that the sort of more crisis phase
is behind us but this
phase
we're calling the transition phase
is one where the response measures have
to be adapted based on the lessons that
we've learned and the fact that we have
more tools
the recovery
measures have to occur because society
has undertaken a lot of
negative impacts as well as our health
systems
and be ready so the readiness aspect
that we all have to understand is you
know get ready for a potential
uh worse variant than what we've seen
um i think is actually really important
to do it may or may not happen but with
so many changes in the virus are being
undertaken around the world and not
the whole world has had
good enough vaccination uptake the next
period of time is
is actually uncertain
nobody likes to hear that word either
but uncertain doesn't mean we don't have
the ability
to be ready and be able to manage
the resurgences with with less societal
impact and as i said we need to be ready
for the fall
in case we need to um up our game again
i don't know exactly what
policies may need to be reinstituted but
i know there'll be a big effort to
reduce the heavier sort of restrictive
measures
but maybe reinstitute less heavy
measures like mask
requirements in certain settings
and of course we are
trying to look at the vaccination
strategy going forwards as well
yeah when you when you talk about public
health measures your advice isn't only
about you know
what would be most effective from health
perspective there's also you know what
people will accept in a political
element to that to some extent um
some of these measures are very
politically fraught right now like
vaccine mandates
um do you see a world where they might
return
well i don't know i think is what
um
at different levels of the system people
think
it would be the most effective in
protecting their populations and
protecting each other
uh but i think that um the collective
uh
objective is is is the following which
is to be able to reduce the severe
outcomes the hospitalizations
the more the deaths that have
unfortunately occurred we want to
prevent those we want to protect those
at the highest risk
of severe outcomes but also those at a
higher risk of the severe impact of the
pain they're making the measures
and being to balance that with
it's minimizing impacts on society
and with that in mind they are difficult
balances i think we at a better
situation now than we were before and be
able to achieve that
and with that comes i think less um
perhaps a need for some of these more
more restrictive measures
but um you know i don't think we should
be able to discount them entirely um but
the as i said the collective objective
is to move from requirements to
recommendations but if if ovarian occurs
and people are
impacted severely then i'm sure
all of these policies will again be
re-examined
thank you next question vic adopia cbc
thanks doctors for taking my question um
i would just want to change gears a bit
uh
you you know that astrazeneca's new
pre-exposure covert therapy has been
approved by health canada how do you see
that being used in this pandemic or in
this stage of the pandemic
now i'm sure the last comment is correct
i know that
what was announced was a advanced
purchase agreement to
obtain some doses
when the regulatory authority that's how
canada
authorizes its use
um so
that's just
something that should be verified and i
can't uh comment on the regulatory
timelines
but what um this
additional
antibody
um
preventive measure is
designed to do is
mostly for people who
who don't develop
a good immune response to
either um the vaccines or
um
or even infection with a virus
they can't mount a good
antibody response
to to those um
to those under those circumstances it is
another option
to provide the antibody as what we call
passive
prevention
and i think that the idea is that it is
um could be helpful to people who are
immunocompromised or with underlying
risk factors
um particularly if you are not able to
be vaccinated
but we expect also guidance to be
developed
on the use of this
new tool
as
as the regulatory authorizations
progress i don't know if doctor knew you
have anything further to add
not much more to add dr tam other than
to say that it is a a potentially new uh
tool that could also be used in a
certain context as you indicated and
i i would put it that you know certainly
uh we talked about monoclonal antibodies
that there might be a bit of confusion
uh the ones that are currently in use
now are more on the treatment side so
for those individuals who actually i do
get the infection and
you know i i end up maybe with a more
serious illness certainly they've been
used to good effect in sort of the
hospital and healthcare setting uh this
new product
uh if it does get approved by health
canada i think it's more we say on the
prophylactic side in terms of trying to
uh prevent individuals who for whatever
reason may not benefit from vaccinations
so on so that they are protected
against infection and then obviously
more serious consequences thanks
and uh yeah my apologies for that
assumption uh about its approval uh the
other question is
should this or would this be available
to someone who um has turned down being
vaccinated if um they're you know
logically at higher risk of of getting
infected with coca-19 and having more
serious outcomes
yeah as i said there would be guidance
at some point provided but just as with
some of the treatment measures it should
be based on data on who's at the highest
risk and so i think um
you know that that's the bottom line and
and it doesn't necessarily matter
whether someone has been vaccinated or
not if they can't mount a response or
for whatever reason is not vaccinated
then it is an option
for people
but
you know
its use is a lot more
complicated even if it's longer lasting
is also not gonna be
you know
long term
uh one wouldn't suspect as as we've seen
these kind of preventive antibodies
being used in the past they're only for
certain periods of time as well
and vaccines still remain
the most effective
population based
measure for preventing
this virus
impact
i see no further show of hands on the
zoom so thank you that concludes today's
press conference thank you very much
doctors thank you very much
bye